[Music]
welcome to session number 66 in the
world of speculative fiction series this
is the eighth year that's January 2023
and we are beginning by picking up a
series which we started last year
looking at the first two books in Dan
Simmons Hyperion cantos Hyperion in the
fall of Hyperion now for this session we
are looking at the last two books in the
series uh Endymion and the rise of
Endymion kind of some nice parallelism
there air between rise and fall and
these books are a little bit thicker
than the others they come in at around
600 and 700 pages so a lot going on and
they they answer a lot of questions they
ramp up a lot of loose ends and
introduce so many other threads of the
narrative world that Dan Simmons is is
creating that we're going to have a lot
to to discuss with this now for those
who are tuning in and not familiar with
the worlds of speculative fiction series
is we started this series back in 2016
as an in-person
discussion and you know focusing on
philosophical themes authors plots
characters narrative universes and it it
proved to be very successful and the
people who were interested in it were
quite engaged it was hosted by the
Brookfield Public Library here in the
greater Milwaukee area then when we hit
covid in 2020 20 yeah 20 we had to shift
gears a little bit for a while we
weren't meeting at all and then we moved
to this sort of format where I present
for about 90 minutes talking about these
books and all the things that are going
on in them we do a live chat which
perhaps you might be participating in
right now with a video premiere and then
we follow it up with about another 90
minutes or so of video conferencing
using Zoom to have a continued
discussion of all the issues so we are
going to be digging into Endymion and
Rise of Endymion I actually found these
to be just as is
interesting enjoyable engaging as the
first two books perhaps even more so for
me in part because there are so many
interesting
philosophical themes literally Cosmic in
scope that are worked out and gradually
revealed in these two works new
characters are introduced old characters
are brought back in some of them
seemingly brought back to life that had
died in the we thought they died in the
earlier works and there's so much
interesting stuff going on we don't need
to do biography since we did that in the
previous session so we'll probably Jump
Right In by looking at some of the
things that Simmons himself says about
these two volumes
some of the things that other people
have had to say positive and negative
and then we're going to get into the
narrative universe that is you know
originally introduced here and then is
further developed in the second two uh
the the third and fourth book of these
Hyperion cantos I will mention one other
thing which we're going to talk about at
greater length the Hyperion cantos
the series are these four books but the
Hyperion cantos is also a text
discussed and referenced in these two
books so there's a little bit of meta
going on there I don't want to talk
about that too long though so let's jump
now into looking at what Simmons himself
has to tell us about these uh these
books and the series as a whole that you
might find hopefully as interesting as I
do
given the amount of space or rather time
that we devoted to looking at the
interviews that Dan Simmons has given
about Hyperion its characters its plot
and artificial intelligence all those
sorts of things in the previous session
I don't think we need to go back over
that again and I think it could be
useful just to focus primarily on some
reviews and many of them are quite
critical of these third and fourth books
within the cantos I think that some of
the reviews are off in certain places
and we'll talk about that I do want to
bring up one thing from Simmons that he
said in Locust in an interview and this
will be the only interview bit he says
that the rise of Endymion is absolutely
the last of the Hyperion books he says
also it's not the absolutely last thing
I'm going to write I'm going to write a
little novelette but it is the last
novel
sometimes it's a dirty trick when a
writer continues a tale and you find out
they were unreliable narrators or
something that seemed to be told in all
Candor actually wasn't as it appeared
that irritates me sometimes when I read
but I did that in the fall of Hyperion
some of the things in Hyperion were not
as first perceived and I have to say in
the rise of Endymion there is more of
that not in the sense of a trick I hope
but in the sense of finally getting a
clear perspective on what was going on
in the preceding three books
and I think that we can say that that
also happens in Endymion itself we learn
more about the architecture of the
universe and what's going on with the
autonomous intelligences in the Techno
core and the firecaster network and the
void that binds and things like that but
he is right there's a lot more in the
rise of Endymion that is being revealed
through all of these dialogues
discussions plot points and so that's
that's quite important and I think I
think there's a distinction there that's
quite significance so he says that I'm
not going to write some more novels
after these and make use of the
unreliable narrator or you know I'm just
joking here it was all a dream and
here's the real reality or something
like that this is it this is the end of
the Hyperion cantos
but
um there is going to be a lot of
additional Revelation that has to happen
along the way and the question that we
should ask because some of the people
accuse him of doing retconning is
is that really the appropriate idea or
is it more the traditional
you know uh I won't say Trope or
technique but impulse to reveal more and
more and more of reality that does fit
cohesively together
as we go on so that's worth keeping in
mind
so I really only have three authors for
reviews but three authors that I'm going
to bring up so in the New York Times
review Gerald Jonas says for vastness of
scope Clarity of detail and seriousness
of purpose Simmons epic narrative is on
a par with Isaac asimov's Foundation
series Frank Herbert's Dune books Gene
Wolf's multi-part book of the new sun
and Brian aldous's heliconia Trilogy no
one in modern science fiction not even
wolf has dealt more sensitively with the
interface between religion and science
yet the rise of Endymion like the three
predecessors is also a full-blooded
action novel replete with personal
combats in battles in space that are
distinguished from formulaic Space Opera
by the magnitude of what is at stake
which is nothing less than the salvation
of the human soul so let's pause on that
for a moment there's there's a lot in
that first paragraph that I think is
quite right
so there is Space Opera elements in this
right
there's the you know we could call it
travel narrative going through these
fire casters from world to world to
world I mean sort of renderland in some
parts of Philip Jose Farmer's world of
Tears
um you know where you go through these
portals and it's kind of a cool plot
device allowing you to overcome the
distance between worlds and um you know
there is the let's shoot a mop out in
space cool stuff going on
but
um this is right that all of that stuff
is happening within the framework of a
bigger story that has to do with the
the purpose the ends the development
of humanity in relation not just to its
own uh one-time Creations although
they've gone on their own the you know
autonomous intelligences but also others
as well you know it's a cosmos that we
inhabit with other races now
is it out of par with Isaac asimov's
Foundation series
I would actually say this is way better
than the foundation series and you know
it's aided by the fact that the
foundation series at least the original
ones are not very long you know compared
to what's going on in in these Works
um the Dune okay Dune begins with a
really really amazing great first novel
and then you know it's good but not
absolutely outstanding the rest of the
developments and you know there is this
great theme of where is human Humanity
going
I'm willing to say that the Hyperion
cantos is actually on the whole better
than the Dune series at least the stuff
that Frank Herbert himself wrote not to
mention the stuff that his his son
writes afterwards
um Gene Wolf's book of the new son okay
now I think we're in the same territory
I think we could say that our Scott
backers works I think that we could say
CJ
cherries Alliance Union Universe which
of course has many other books in which
we get to receive revealed over over
time as well
um those are maybe the peers for this
this uh set of novels really as as
Simmons has said two big novels Each of
which is in two books so this is the
second novel in the third and fourth
book
all right so going on with uh Jonas's
review in reviewing the first two books
in the series Hyperion and sequel the
fall of Hyperion I noted that they
actually constituted a single thousand
page novel that should be read from the
beginning this is you know the same in
um I'm not sure how comprehensible they
would be to readers unfamiliar with the
rest of the series but taken together
the four volumes represent one of the
finest achievements of modern science
fiction a convincing demonstration of
how liberating in the hands of a master
League practitioner genre conventions
can be I think that's a good point as
well so Simmons is working with a lot of
different we could call them sub-genres
and weaving them in together and making
use of them so I mean to be fair to
Asimov and Herbert and others before
maybe we could say well without them
coming before no Simmons later on but
there's there's a
certainly a leap in quality here
he says in previous books of this series
Simmons alternates between impassioned
discussions and moral issues and scenes
of action rendered with an agonizing
slow motion Precision he takes the
reader to planets and habitats of lavish
complexity and agreeable strangeness
even when the arena shifts to the
metaphysical endymion's ingrained
distaste for rhetoric keeps the language
lean and grounded that is Beth Simmons
knows how to light up a faded conceit
the story of Aina and her Mission
involves so many Mysteries within
Mysteries that just when you begin to
think Simmons cannot possibly remember
let alone untangle them he reveals how
neatly they all fit together in the
service of his overarching theme which
is that prolonging life is less
important than enriching life and a
merely physical immortality is just
another kind of death so again let's uh
take a pause for a second
important distinction that goes all the
way back to ancient political Theory
between Zayn living life
and
living well which somebody like
Aristotle takes to be possible really
only within the scope of a community at
least for human beings who are neither
animals nor Gods but somewhere in
between and I think that really is a
central theme to these Works survival of
the species survival in terms of
maintaining power structures that are
going to give the human race an order
and a a Direction versus you know the
capacity for autonomous
self-determination and Discovery in
relation to others how are these
supposed to work together Humanity
itself is divided into the ousters along
with the Templars you know who were
originally in the hegemony and then you
know are now with the ousters and the
Pacs and the church you know from the
hegemony and then you know the the
technocore which is itself divided into
a whole bunch of things so that that's
enough to draw out of that review
another interesting one is not another
feminist science fiction review of the
Hyperion cantos by Barbara gergel which
I partly agree with and partly disagree
with
she talks about the series and she does
a little bit of you know summary which
could be useful for those who haven't
actually read everything so I'm going to
read what she has to say because it
might be useful for some of you
Hyperion tells the story of the Selvin
pilgrims and their lives and their
individual encounters with the shrike we
meet father Leonard Hoyt a priest of the
nearly defunct Catholic Church fademan
kassad a retired Corporal with a
reputation for ruthlessness Brawn lamia
a female private eye who's in love with
a cyborg Reincarnation of the 18th
century English poet John Keats and who
appears to have stepped directly out of
a Noir detective novel complete with
trench coat and sixth shooter saw a
Weintraub a religious scholar who is
bringing his infant daughter Rachel to
Hyperion in an attempt to cure her
Merlin's disease which causes her to age
backwards Martin selenis an aged and
lecherous poet born centuries earlier on
Old Earth and kept alive through a
mixture of hyper-speed food Fugue and
wealth hetmasting a Templar priest who
commands a Starship that's actually a
tree and the council a state agent and
former governor of the city of Cates on
the fam Planet Hyperion who has been
asked by Gladstone the CEO of the
hegemony to attend the pilgrimage due to
reports of an ouster spy among them in
each of their stories they tell how they
first encountered the shrike what led
them to embark on this pilgrimage now
they travel to the apparent home of the
shrike the time tombs a series of
tunnels that travel backwards through
time to either make a wish or to attempt
to kill it
Endymion leaps forward more than 200
years to tell the story of the daughter
of Braun lamia and the first cyborg
Cates this trial is actually the
physical manifestation of empathy part
of the Trinity of God that mankind
creates in the distant future is part of
their war against the Techno course own
God the ultimate intelligence
the rise of Endymion brings to fruition
the burgeoning collaboration between the
newly revived Catholic church and the
technocore that we see at the end of the
fall of Hyperion and Endymion and
lamia's human AI child Ayanna has
amassed a cult following due to her
threat to the packs current Catholic
Intergalactic government somehow the
time traveling AI God baby is not the
most confusing or highly criticized
aspect of this series and then she
starts talking about criticism so this
is some good summary now here's here's
some of the criticisms the prevailing
criticism of the series is not simply
that the latter three books are not as
good as the first a more accurate
characterization would be that the main
problem present in books two through
four is also present in book one though
to a lesser extent book one is just good
enough for readers to overlook the
sexism these aren't new problems as
could be explained by countless feminist
Science Fiction and Fantasy writers and
so she's going to go into that now we
should pause for a second
is it really the case that
book one is the really stand out great
book and then these other three books
that come afterwards uh followed by
period Endymion and the rise of Endymion
are just not as good and more flawed
yeah there's some criticisms out there
the question is are the criticisms valid
or true or on point I think they're not
I I think that the series actually
Hyperion sets a high standard and the
other three novels
um manage to follow it up it's not like
Dune where the first one is really the
best and the others are good but and
they're filling in pictures but they're
just not as good I don't think that's
the case at all
now she talks about sexism
and this is where it gets quite
interesting I think so she says she's
going to admit that Simmons is actually
getting around other ways of being
sexist and then she'll accuse him of a
different sort so she says
the series contends with its own flavor
of sexism perhaps more subtle in some
respects than say the dearth of female
characters in tolkien's writing we do in
fact see many female characters in The
Hyperion Series so you know good
admission there
um
the CEO not only do women exist in
Simmons world but they're often powerful
the CEO of The Intergalactic human
communities a woman or more accurately a
thatcher slash Merkel slash Clinton
Amalgamated archetype in a power suit
the lone female Pilgrim is a
muscle-bound powerful detective that at
one point kills a man with her thighs
kassad's greatest Nemesis is a former
lover named monetta who helps him
Slaughter thousands of ousters and later
rapes him while they're covered with the
blood of their enemies and might be the
shrike and you know the new Messiah in
books three and four is lamia's grown
daughter who is often very worried about
the delicate feelings of her older
boyfriend all these characters get
basically one big important thing to do
and then later recede into decorative
lamps in the background
the toughest nails but pregnant
detective who can lift Men by the collar
later ends up sleeping with the
lecherous old poet who hates her and at
one point had himself gene spliced into
a sadder you get the picture it's not
simply the treatment of the lady
characters that give the aura of
misogyny
um knowing sci-fi and fantasy lack
female characters Simmons includes a lot
of them knowing that the genre writes
women simply as objects of men's desire
he writes undesirable women knowing that
slaying the dragon is traditionally a
job for men Simmons makes his Slayers in
his dragon as female but bucking known
tropes for the heck of it while failing
to address the Deep undercurrent of
misogyny in an entire series does not
lead to a much better outcome now here's
where we can see an interesting
criticism being made all these
admissions yeah he did this and this and
this and this and you can say so that's
not enough for for you as the critic he
is actually very thoughtfully uh
developing characters who aren't just
one trick ponies I don't think that
lamia is I don't think that Gladstone is
I don't think that Aina is by any
stretch and even
um monetta who turns out to be Rachel
uh I don't think that that fits with
with her and there are other characters
as well who who show up playing a
significant role
she claims that the misogyny is that
female characters are vastly outnumbered
than those that do exist are boring the
Messiah character is Young and sexy yet
innocent there's a female assassin who's
deadly but sexy and vulnerable the
leader of mankind is once again a man a
priest no less even the genderless
Android is coded as male books three and
four are entirely about how you know the
AI God Baby is fighting the packs for
the soul of mankind the books are named
after Raul Enderman a blundering hunting
guide who comes completely undone when
he learns that during a two-year
separation between him and Aina she has
sex with another man who later turns out
to be him from the future it's you know
so it goes on as well so we should think
about this is this a fair criticism
um I mean I have to leave that to the
readers to decide whether you know Aina
is really this
kind of insipid stock character or
whether she's quite Dynamic I I read it
as that I mean she and you know why is
it told Through The Eyes of Raul and
Damian and also you know Captain DeSoto
um well Raul tells you that later on in
the story uh and I I kind of think that
maybe the critic here forgot about that
um you know it turns out that he's not
actually her protector he's actually
sort of her recorder so she's in a much
greater position than than he is
um so I mean that's that's worth
thinking about
um she goes out and says in Hyperion the
sexism is Redeemed by The Format of the
storytelling the deep and intricate
World building and interesting and
dynamic characters
um
I have recommended hyperion to everyone
who likes science fiction it was the
love of the first book that kept me
reading through three more even though
they were frankly not good hyperion's
questions or clumsily answered in the
other three books I don't know I I I
don't really buy that myself this seems
like a kind of reading that missed some
of what was going on in part so I could
focus in on a sexism that perhaps is
there perhaps not you know and I'd like
to know how things could be undone
structurally in this and maybe the point
of comparison would be to CJ chera's
Alliance Union Universe you know
um but that would that would require
some additional work now I do have one
other review that I wanted to bring up a
set of reviews rather both by Russ
Albury so he reviews first Endymion and
then reviews the rise of Endymion and he
says in Damian is the weakest book in
the Hyperion series well some hooks were
left for a sequel Endymion feels a
little bit bolted on at times and
Simmons engages in some retconning
retroactively changing or reinterpreting
the past story it's also a less
interesting story it doesn't have the
storytelling Brilliance of Hyperion or
the Space Opera sweep of the fall of
Hyperion and sometimes feels boring or
pointless it's mostly a travelogue how
much you enjoy the book is likely to
have a lot to do with how interesting
you find the exploration of Worlds of
the old hegemony
so let's pause there I I mean I didn't
find it
um
boring at all and I didn't find it to be
lacking the storytelling Brilliance or
Space Opera sweep
um I mean I will admit that I think he
is on to something the jumping Between
Worlds travelogue thing I also found
that a little bit
you know
um after a while doll and I've already
brought up the you know Farmers world of
Tears when they go from world to world
to World
um but that's not all that's going on in
these Explorations so I I think that um
Albury might have lost the point of what
what else is happening right he says
there's a larger plot though andymion
introduces the Pax the new government
that's taken over after the conclusion
of the fall of Hyperion and now
dominates mankind far more than the
hegemony did right
half the book is told from the
perspective of Raul and Demian the other
half from the perspective of the priest
of the Pax who is chasing Raul and Aina
and the pack sections I thought were the
strongest in the book okay there's
there's something there right uh
exploring a uh uh religious rotten
full of potential not being realized but
being crushed organization that has
become essentially the evil empire yeah
yeah there's there's a lot to be worked
with there
um
he uh he winds up saying much of the
trouble with Endymion is that it's a
bridge book it's trying to take the
world of a mostly completed Space Opera
story
and prepare it as a backdrop in which to
tell a very different story about
religion belief in Messiahs accordingly
it's neither fiction or foul and ends up
feeling occasionally forced leaves one
with the feeling that not a lot really
happened the rise of Endymion is the
real payoff to this story and Endymion
serves primarily to get the reader to
the point where the story can be told I
think that's wrong
um there's a lot that goes on within the
story not just World building not just
character development not just
retconning as as he's calling it which
you know is better understood is like
revealing more of the dimensions that
that were there just waiting to be
uncovered and you know so I think that
um it is it is a bridge book in a sense
but that doesn't have to lower it in
quality a bridge can be constructed
shoddily or a bridge can be constructed
well and I think that in this case
it is really constructed well and the
idea that nothing happens
I mean the shrike is revealed to be not
just this enemy of humankind but
actually protecting Aina and escapes its
its boundaries the uh fact of you know
the resurrection
cruciform or parasites being used in
particular ships where these poor
bastards have to die and be resurrected
over and over again the introduction of
you know the sort of uh
amped up Terminators coming from the
machine Corps who are trying to kill
um Aina and anybody else connected with
her and then the Turning of the Pax crew
with Father DeSoto attacking that very
being saving uh Ayanna and Raul and and
you know betnik and all the others from
that I mean this is um this is some real
action here it's not like nothing does
happen in Endymion
uh he continues with another review
the rise of Endymion completes the
transition started in Endymion and takes
the story of the Hyperion Universe in a
very different direction this is not a
story about Interstellar governments or
Space Battles although both do feature
in it it's the gospel of a messiah of
empathetic humanism set against the
backdrop of a Space Opera Universe I I
think that's actually right I think that
um that's a good characterization of
what's happening in these and
particularly in diminish rise of
Endymion I think it's there in Endymion
itself
um and so you know he goes on aina's
philosophy focuses on individuals and
their relationships on trust communities
forgiveness Redemption and non-violent
resistance instead of violence it
focuses on love and more broadly on
connections between people on fostering
and creating life now that's going a
little too far there is fighting there
is defending there is attacking you know
uh the shrike plays a very important
role as does kassad who becomes the
shrike by the way but that's that's
largely right there's there's something
that's being missing on the part of some
of the humans and some of the AIS that
Aina is able to bring to the human race
spread out through the the cosmos
um so he goes on and he says the story
is told in the form of a gospel a first
person account written by our companion
and lover and Catholic and Christian
imagery is used extensively throughout
the traditional form of church rituals
are a centerpiece of the Pax Church
which lays claim to Catholic tradition
well underneath is an exercise in
cynical technology aina's rituals are
superficially ways of interacting with
physical laws and science but take on
the form of those same Christian rituals
redeeming them for something closer to
their spiritual purpose okay that is
true and uh Buddhism plays a role and
other things play a role as well it's
not just Catholic and Christian
and he goes on he says I can come up
with many reasons why someone would
dislike this book The retconning is
blatant at times
it depends on what you consider red
cutting right if if that's a killer for
you then probably it's not a good book
200 Pages could have been trimmed uh
from the book I never did understand the
point of the geography tour and list of
names on tianchon
that that's more I would say admitting
that one doesn't get why parts of the
story are in there parts of it Meander
badly the technology and physics are
often frankly unbelievable and the
Viewpoint character can be quite stupid
at times
maybe the Viewpoint character is
actually supposed to be quite stupid you
know maybe that's part of why he's in
the place that he's in
then he goes out and he says and yet I
love this book Aina is one of my
favorite fictional characters and that's
an amazing feat for a character who is
cast on the role of Messiah carrying
with it both foreknowledge and near
infallibility which she doesn't actually
have she can see Futures but she's not
sure which is going to be which
throughout the story she exudes an
enthusiastic joy and love of life that's
infectious and delightful to read she
also has the best two per word mission
statement of any religious figure I've
read about here's a really interesting
observation and this is where we get to
the end of the reviews
this book reminds me of what Star Wars
could be if it had more fully developed
a humanist philosophy around the force
and explored the implications for the
universe of something like the force
existing there's a Space Opera plot over
underlying mysticism lush world building
focusing on images and Impressions
rather than geology and planetary
physics and odd cultures tucked into the
corners of the Galaxy
um the ending though put Star Wars to
shame even knowing exactly what was
coming this being my second reading this
is an important uh Criterion I love the
twists and emotional climax of it
can the books can the the composition
The Narrative universe
profit from a second reading that is
what makes things Classics you know the
fact that you can go back to them and
find more and more and more in them so
these are some uh you know we went
through some reviews we've already
revealed some of what's going on in
these now we got to talk about some of
the World building that's uh happening
in here some of the let's call it
retconning if people want but let's also
call it Revelation and the key
philosophical themes that we find in
these two novels
there are so many incredible
philosophical themes woven into Endymion
and the rise of Endymion and spanning
this entire set of works that we call
the Hyperion cantus that it's rather
difficult to decide
where to go in where to start and so I
thought that arbitrarily one of the best
places that we might begin is with the
notion of the cantos themselves and what
that's supposed to mean so what we've
got here is a bit of recursivity or if
you like you know the work itself is
included in the work or referenced
within the work which by itself is an
interesting idea and so you could think
of the Hyperion cantos as the production
of Martin salenius
that covers what happens in these first
two books and that is indeed largely
correct
but we're going to find out by the very
end that the cantos were never finished
but they're able to be finished
and the cantos themselves are connected
up with the this figure
um you know our our main point of view
character of Raul and Demian the
Endymion that this is named after right
but he's not really in in many respects
the main character the most important
character is Aina
um who he is charged with protecting and
we'll talk about that in just a bit and
all the things that she's going to learn
and teach and project out onto humankind
um it's you know there's also uh de soya
the priest Captain who uh things are
told in a a third person for him and we
begin and essentially we end with Raul
stuck in a prison cell and then
eventually getting out of it so the the
whole story begins like this which is
kind of a rather enigmatic idea you are
reading this for the wrong reason so
this is at the very beginning of the the
third book if you are reading this to
learn what it was like to make love to a
messiah our Messiah then you should not
read on because you're a little more
than a voyeur now I might say what never
occurred to me to to read for that
reason you just kind of put that in my
head and he goes on if you're reading
this because you're a fan of the old
poets cantos and are obsessed with
curiosity about what happened next in
the lives of the Hyperion pilgrims you
will be disappointed I do not know what
happened to most of them they lived and
died almost three centuries before I was
born
now most of them yes technically
speaking but we are going to see some of
those who we thought Dead coming back if
you're reading this because you seek
more insight into the message from the
one who teaches you may also be
disappointed I confess that I was more
interested in her as a woman that as a
teacher or Messiah not quite true
finally if you're reading this to
discover her fate or even my fate you're
reading the wrong document although both
of our Fates seem as certain as anyone's
could be I was not with her when hers
was played out and my own awaits the
Final Act even as I write these words
not quite true either if you're reading
this at all I would be amazed but this
would not be the first time that events
have amazed me the past few years have
been one improbability after another
each more marvelous and seemingly
inevitable than the last to share the
memories and is the reason I am writing
perhaps the motivation is not even to
share knowing that the document I am
creating almost certainly will never be
found but just to put down the series of
events so I can structure them in my own
mind
kind of a you know Message in a Bottle
getting my own thoughts clear and of
course we did get his his thoughts
because they're spanning all of these
books right
and he says
um I am writing this in a schrodiger cat
box in high orbit around the quarantine
world of armagast the cat box is not
much of a box more of a smooth hauled
ovoid a mere six meters by three meters
that it will be my entire world until
the end of my life most of the interior
of my world is a Spartan cell consisting
of a black box air and waste recycler my
bunk the food synthesizer unit a narrow
counter that serves as both my writing
table and writing desk and finally the
toilet sink and shower which are set
behind a fiber plastic partition for
reasons of propriety that escaped me no
one will ever visit me here privacy
seems a hollow joke I have a text slate
and stylus when I finish each page I
transfer it to hard copy on micro Vellum
produced by the recycler the low
accretion of wafer than pages is the
only visible change in my environment
from day to day the vial of poison gas
is not visible it is set in the static
Dynamic shell of the cat box linked to
the air filtration unit in such a way
that to attempt to fiddle with it would
trigger the cyanide as would any attempt
to breach the shell itself the radiation
detector its timer and the isotope
element are also fused into the Frozen
energy of the shell I never know when
the random timer activates the detector
I never know when the same random timing
element opens the lead shielding to the
tiny isotope I never know when the
isotope yields a particle but I will
know when the detector is activated at
the instant the isotope yields a
particle there should be the scent of
bitter almonds in that second or two
before the gas kills me right he says
technically according to the ancient
Enigma of quantum physics I am now
neither dead nor alive I am in the
suspended state of overlapping
probability waves once reserved for the
cat intrudinger's thought experiment and
so this is you know quite an interesting
start it's sort of like you know it's a
Trope at this point you know you might
think of the movie DOA where a person
walks into a police station and says I
want a report a murder they say who's
and he's he says mine right he's going
to die and it's uh interestingly from
radiation
um then he recounts his story and that
is what we're getting through most of
this and we even have vignettes where he
in Rise of Endymion where he's in the
cell right
we learn about that but first we have to
come back to the cantos themselves so
in the story Raul is on Hyperion the you
know place where all of this took place
well most of which took place uh in
those earlier books and uh he's
sentenced to death because of a a mishap
with a bunch of Rich jerks who he has to
lead on a Hunting Expedition and he
saved from the execution uh people think
he is executed and then he's brought to
uh our character Martin Salinas
so we have this vignette
the old man said you can run an errand
for me and become rich
tell me I said the old man closed his
eyes and rattled in a deep breath can
you read Raul and Demian yes have you
read the poem known as the cantos no but
you've heard some of it surely being
born into one of the nomadic Shepherd
clans of the north the Storyteller has
touched on the cantos there's a strange
tone in the cracked voice modesty
perhaps I've heard bits of it my clan
preferred the garden epic or the Glen
and height Saga the Saturn figures
crease into a smile the garden epic yes
Raul was a centaur hero in that what was
he not I said nothing Grand Ammon loved
the character of the Centaur named Raul
my mother and I had both grown up
listening to Tales of him
do you believe the stories snap the old
man the cantos tales I mean believe them
I said that they actually happened that
way the pilgrims and the shrike and all
that I paused a minute there were those
who believed all the Tall Tales told in
the cantos and there were those who
believed none of it that it was all myth
and monitoring thrown together to add
mystery to the ugly war and confusion
that was the fall
I never really thought about it I said
truthfully does it matter
the old man seemed to be choking but
then I realized the dry rattling sounds
were Chuckles not really he said at last
now listen I will tell you the outline
of the errand it takes energy for me to
speak uh so he tells them
My Story begins almost 270 some years
ago during the fall one of the pilgrims
in the cantos was a friend of mine her
name was Braun lamia she was real after
the fall after the death of the hegemony
and the opening of the time tombs Braun
lamia gave birth to a daughter the
child's name was Diana but the little
girl was headstrong and changed her name
almost as soon as she was able to talk
for a while she was known as Cynthia
then Kate short for hekate then when she
turned 12 she insisted that her friends
and family call her tummus when I last
saw her she was called Aina
um the old man stopped and squinted at
me if you think this is not important
you think this is not important but
names are important if you had not been
named after this city which in turn
named after an ancient poem you would
not have come to my attention and you
would not be here today you would be
dead do you understand Raul and Demian
no I said he should have said it doesn't
matter where was I the last time you saw
the child she called herself Aina
yes she was not an inspection especially
attractive child but she was unique
everyone who knew or felt she was
different special not spoiled despite
all the nonsense with the name changes
just different have you ever met someone
who is profoundly different Raul and
Demian and he goes on as well
um
and he says of course Braun knew the
child was special before she was born he
stopped and opened his eyes enough to
squint at me you've heard this part of
the con the cantos yes I said it was
foretold by a sybrid entity that the
woman named lamia was to give birth to a
child known as the one who teaches
I thought that the old man was going to
spit a stupid title no one called Anna
during the time I knew her she was
simply a child brilliant and headstrong
but a child everything that was unique
was unique only in potential
but then bra and lamia died and Anna
disappeared she was 12. technically I
was her guardian but she did not ask my
permission to disappear one day she left
and I never heard from her again
I never heard from her but I know where
she went and where she will reappear the
time tombs are off limits now
but do you remember the names and
functions of the tombs Raul and Demian
and they go on as well and they talk
about what's going to be his mission
so
he's asked do you remember where the
Sphinx LED boy according to the cantos I
said Saul Weintraub and his daughter
traveled to the distant future through
the Sphinx
yes
whispered the ancient thing in the
hoverbed Saul and Rachel and a few
others disappeared into the Sphinx
before the pack sealed it and closed off
the Valley of the time tombs many tried
in those early days tried to find a
shortcut to the future but the Sphinx
seemed to choose whom I travel through
its tunnel in time and then uh
Selena says do you know what I'm going
to ask of you and Raul says no although
again I had a strong suspicion
I want you to go after my ANA I want you
to find her to protect her from the
packs to flee with her and when she has
grown up and become what she must become
to give her a message I want you to tell
her her uncle Martin is dying and if she
wishes to speak to him again she must
come home
and so you know this is setting things
up he also says I've got some other
things I want you to do you're going to
have to protect her from the packs
you're going to have to do all these
other things as well you're gonna have
to undo the Pax and the church
and figure out what the AI techno core
is up to and Ravel is like oh well
anything else you want with that but
that is the the core of the story
um he's also telling them you're going
to travel the river tethers now the
river tethace was in these books a
series of rivers on over I believe 200
worlds throughout the hegemony connected
together by farcaster portals which
allowed instant teleportation from One
River on one planet to another and so
you could sail down this entire River
traveling throughout
space all over these different worlds
and so that is uh described in the
cantos and that's what's going to be
happening now the going on a little bit
further
this is in um with father Captain
Federico De soya and it's talking about
church history and the cantos
both accounts church history and the
Forbidden cantos the Church of the time
has outlawed reading of it but many
people within the church do in fact read
it because it's forbidden and because it
might reveal information both accounts
agreed it had been father duray who
during his Exile on the Outback world of
Hyperion who discovered the Symbiote
called the cruciform and we're going to
talk more about that in just a bit there
the histories had diverged Beyond
reconciliation according to the poem
durray had received the cruciform from
the alien creature called the shrike
according to the church's teachings the
shrike a representation of Satan if
there ever was one had nothing to do
with the discovery of the cruciform but
it later tempted both father duray and
father Hoyt the church's history
reported only DeRay had succumbed to the
creatures treachery the cantos told in
their confused mix of pagan mythology
and garbled history how durray had
crucified himself in the flame force of
hyperion's pinion Plateau rather than
return the cruciform to the church
according to the Pagan poet Martin
solenis this was to save the church from
Reliance on a parasite
in place of Faith according to church
history which de soya believed durray
had crucified himself to end the pain
the Symbiote caused him and in Alliance
with the shrike demon to prevent the
church which DeRay considered his enemy
after having excommunicated him from
regaining its VI its Vitality through
the discovery of the sacrament of
Resurrection so what we see here is that
the cantos are very important for
providing a counter-narrative to the
church's
revisionist teachings about history
uh we get to see some other discussion
of the cantos coming up in something
that we'll have to go back to in a bit
the what's going on with the Techno core
so
Aina and Raul are talking and uh he says
or she says did Uncle Martin's poem
explain the motivations of these three
important factions within the technocore
The Stables volatiles and ultimates and
he says more or less it's hard to follow
the poem has umen and the other core AI
speaking in Zen Cohen's Anna NADA that's
about right according to the cantos I
said the group of core AIS known as The
Stables wanted to keep being parasites
on our human brains the volatiles wanted
to wipe us out and the ultimates didn't
give much of a damn as long as they
could keep working on their machine God
so this is you know an important
reference to it and then here's another
key idea coming up
not all the forecaster portals were
built or maintained by The Stables to be
how did you put it like big ticks on our
brains all right I said well who built
the forecasters who else built the
forecasters
the river tethers forecasters were
designed by the ultimates said Aina they
were an experiment I guess you could say
with the void which binds that's the
core phrase did Martin use it in his
cantos yeah I said
um
I never understood what the hell the
void which binds was supposed to be I
said some sort of hyperspace stuff that
the forecasters used and where the core
was hiding when it prayed on us I got
that part I thought it was destroyed
when Mana Gladstone ordered bombs
dropped into the far casters
you can't destroy the void which binds
said Aina and then she says how did
Martin describe it playing time and
Planck length I said I don't remember
exactly something about about combining
the three fundamental constants of
physics gravity's planks constant in the
speed of light
that doesn't really tell me much
and um and so this this important
metaphysical concept is contained in the
cantos but only partially we're going to
see a little bit later on
um it's getting brought up again
so Aina says uh
I understand that the cantos was placed
on the index of prohibited books as soon
as the packs took over everywhere but
what about those worlds not yet
swallowed by the packs when it came out
did he receive the critical Acclaim he
had been hungry for
I remember arguing the cantos in
seminary chuckled father Glaucus we knew
it was prohibited but that just made the
Allure All the greater we resisted
reading Virgil but waited our turn to
read that dog-eared copy of dog roll
that was the cantos was it dogrow asked
Aina I always thought of Uncle Martin as
a great poet but that's only because he
told me he was my mother always told me
he was a pain in the ass poets can be
both said father Glaucus in fact it
seems they often are both as I remember
it most of the critics dismissed the
cantos in what few literary circles
existed before the church absorbed them
some took him seriously as a poet not as
a chronicler of what actually happened
on Hyperion before the fall but most
made fun of his apotheosis of Love
towards the end of his second volume I
remember that I said the characters Saul
the old scholar whose daughter has been
aging backwards he discovers that love
was the answer to what he had called the
Abraham dilemma
I remember one nasty critic who reviewed
the poem in our Capital City chuckled
father Glaucus who quoted some graffiti
found on the wall of an excavated old
Earth City before the hajira if love is
the answer what was the question
Aina looked at me in for an explanation
in the cantos I said the scholar
character seems to discover that the
thing the AI Core had called the void
which binds is love
that love is a basic force of the
universe like gravity and
electromagnetism like strong and weak
nuclear force in the poem Saul sees that
the core ultimate intelligence will
never be capable of understanding that
empathy is inseparable from that Source
from Love
the old poet described love as the sub
Quantum impossibility that carried
information from Photon to Photon tayard
meaning Tara de Chardon would not have
disagreed said father Glaucus although
he would have phrased it differently
anyway I said the almost Universal
reaction to the poem according to Grand
Am was that it was weakened by this
sentimentality
and it was shaking her head
Uncle Martin was right love is one of
the basic forces of the Universe I know
that Saul Weintraub really believed he'd
discovered that he said as much to
mother before he and his daughter
disappeared into the Sphinx riding into
the child's future
so
this is very interesting is it not the
cantos and you know both these books and
the cantos within it
is articulating a vision of the cosmos
not just a history not just a tale
that places love as Central as
underlying everything and it's dismissed
because of that including by the very
church that claims that God is love and
doesn't really exemplify it in many
respects except in certain characters
now towards the end of the rise of
Endymion we're going to get some more
interesting discussions of the cantos
so one of the things that we discover
and this is through a
memory a listening to the voices of the
Dead that Raul and Demian experiences
while in the Schrodinger cage he's
recalling his mother's memories
and they're talking first about you know
the
um
the packs coming in and the cruciform
which we'll get to in a bit because it's
quite important here's the important
part here remember when Raul was telling
Martin Salinas hey I mean I heard the
cantos I didn't really listen to them
that much I like this other stuff better
well that's not quite the case
so Grand Am right uh his his grandmother
and the mother of this this uh his
mother who is talking uh uh Caltran and
Demian
she says uh the grandmother says you
don't have to worry about that I still
remember how to raise a young one I
still have Tales to tell and skills to
teach and I will keep your memory alive
in him Grand Am is squeezing my hand the
young remember most deeply when we are
old and failing it is the memories of
childhood which can be summoned most
clearly
and she goes on and she says do you
remember the voice the verse of ryokan I
taught you when you were barely older
than Raul I have to laugh you taught me
dozens of Rio Converses Grand Am the
first one and so she recites it you used
to like that verse Caltrain and she goes
on and talks about how she's going to
take care of Raul and one of the ways
she takes care of him as we find out in
the rise of Endymion is having him
memorize the cantos so Raul actually
does know the cantos the cantos up to a
certain point and here's where we get
what we could call the big reveal
so
he is in his cell this is in chapter 32
towards the end and he says there was
neither clock nor calendar in my cell I
do not know how many standard days weeks
or months I was beyond the reach of
Sanity I may have gone many days without
sleeping or slept without weeks on end
it is difficult or impossible to tell
but eventually when the cyanide and the
laws of quantum chants continue to spare
me from day to day hour to hour minute
to minute I began this narrative
The Narrative that is the point of view
character stuff in these two books parts
of the Hyperion cantos
I do not know why my imprisoners
provided me with a slate text scriber
and stylus and the ability to print a
few pages of recycled micro Vellum
perhaps they saw the possibility of The
Condemned man writing his confession or
using the scriber stylus as an impotent
way to rage at his judges and jailers
perhaps they saw The Condemned man's
writing of his sins and injuries Joys
and losses of joy is all an additional
source of punishment and perhaps in a
certain way it was but it was also my
salvation at first it saved me from the
insanity and self-destruction of
uncontrollable grief and remorse that
had saved my memories of Aina pulling
them from the Quagmire of horror at her
terrible death to the firmer ground of
our days together her Joy of living her
Mission our travels and her complex but
terribly straightforward message to me
in all humankind eventually it simply
saved my life
soon after beginning The Narrative I
discovered I could share the thoughts
and actions of any of the participants
in our long Odyssey and failed struggle
I knew this was a function of what Aina
had taught me through discussion and
communication with learning the language
of the dead and the language of the
living
I still encountered the dead in my
sleeping and waking dream my mother
often spoke to me and I tasted the agony
and wisdom of uncounted others who had
lived and died long ago
but it was not those lost souls who
obsessed me now it was with it was those
with some parallel view of my own
experiences in all my years of knowing
Aina
so he's putting together a story and
notice what he's saying there parallel
views and experiences we get to see our
own perspective but there's the
perspectives of everybody else by which
the events the experiences the choices
the actions the effects they can change
they can reveal themselves as something
different something greater that is what
he is doing
he says
I you know I entered into at least some
of the thoughts and motives of human
beings so different from my own way of
thinking is to be literally alien
creatures including those who you know
went after him and put him in the box
and killed Aina Cardinal Simon Augusto
Lord Asami and John Domenico Mustafa
Leonard Hoyt in his incarnations as Pope
Julius and Pope Urban this the 16th
mercantilist Traders such as Kenzo
izozaki and anapeli kogani Priests and
warriors such as father de soya Sergeant
Gregorius Captain Margaret Wu an
executive officer Hogan liebler some of
the characters in my tail are present in
the void which binds largely as scars
holds vacancies the nemis creatures
these terrible AI Terminator types are
of are such vacuums as our counselor
Albedo and the other core entities
so he goes on and he talks about all
these different people and he says
although I know without doubt that you
know is dead I never saw her voice among
the chorus of those speaking the
language of the Dead rather I felt her
presence throughout the void which binds
felt her touch in the minds and hearts
of the good people who wandered through
our Odyssey or had their lives changed
forever in our long struggle with the
packs
and he goes on and on
um and uh
he says for a few wonderful days while
writing the text I convinced myself that
Ayanna had returned from the dead that
some sort of Miracle had been possible I
just reached the part of my narrative
where we had reached old Earth passing
through the far Caster on God's Grove
after the terrible encounter with the
first Nemesis thing and then finished
the section with a description of our
arrival at talison West
the night after finishing that first
chunk of the story I dreamed that Ayanna
had come to me there in the Schrodinger
death cell had called my name in the
dark had touched my cheek and whispered
to me we're leaving here Raul my darling
not soon
but as soon as you finish your tail as
soon as you remember it all and
understand it all
when I awoke I'd found that the stylus
scriber had been activated and on its
pages in Hyena's distinctive handwriting
was a long note from her including some
excerpts from hers her father's poetry
so he writes and writes and writes
and then eventually realizes exactly
what was said here
that he can not just forecast but use
this ability that Aina had developed and
was teaching other people to to do it
without a forecaster portal and he comes
back to you know old Earth uh and to all
these other places as well to to the
church world and
um eventually he comes to meet Martin
Salinas and this is where the story
effectively will end for us but also
um the cantos themselves are revealed as
what they are
Martin Salinas was in Good Humor upon
meeting his old friend the uh
man cassad who will become the shrike
right and then cassad says did you ever
finish your worthless prose poem
no I said speaking for the coughing form
in the bed he couldn't this is Raul and
Demian
yes said Martin Salinas clearly through
his throat Mike I did
I just stood there actually said the
poet he finished it for me the Bony arm
with its wrapping of parchment flesh
Rose slightly from the bed a thumb
distorted by arthritis jerked in my
attention
Colonel cassad gave me a glance I shook
my head don't be so dense boy
said Martin Salinas with what translated
as an affectionate tone over the speaker
see your scriber anywhere I Whirled and
looked on the bedside tray where I'd
left it earlier it was gone all printed
out about a billion backup memories cut
sent it out on the datosphere before we
cast here there is no datosphere I said
Martin Salinas laughed himself into a
coughing fit you aren't just dumb boy
you are helpless what do you think the
void is it's the goddamn universe's God
damn dadosphere meaning sort of like the
internet on steroids right
I've been listening to it for centuries
before the kid gave me communion to do
it with nanotech bugs in me that's what
writers and artists and creators do boy
listen to the void and try to hear dead
folks thoughts feel their pain the pain
of living folks too finding a muse is
just an artist or holy man's way of
getting a foot into the void which binds
front door Aina knew that you should
have too
and then Raul says you had no right to
transmit my narrative it's mine I wrote
it it's not part of your cantos
if I'd known for sure which tube passing
it was his oxygen hose I would have
stepped on it till the rattling stopped
boy said Martin Salinas why do
you think I sent you on this 11-year
vacation to rescue Anna the poet cackled
and coughed she didn't need rescuing
Raul hell the way I saw it while it was
happening she pulled your worthless ass
out of the fire more often than not even
when the shrike was doing the saving it
was only because that girl child had
tamed it for a bit the mummy's white
eyes with their video pickup glasses
turned towards Colonel cassad tamed you
I mean you once in future killing
machine I stepped away from the bed and
touched one of the bio monitors to study
myself
Martin salinas's voice called me back
almost haunting me but you haven't
finished it yet boy the kantos aren't
done
I stared at him across the few cold
distances meters of distance what do you
mean old man you've got to take me down
there so we can finish it Raul together
and that is what they do and Salinas
will die his life work complete
Raul's very story and the stories by
extension of everybody else all the
other characters in this are what he
writes and what goes into
Dan Simmons's Hyperion cantos
so it turns out that the Hyperion cantos
doesn't just name this set of four
novels and it doesn't just name a work
within it that narrates what happened in
the first two it is also all of the
events and more
that were included in these and you
could think of it as perhaps we're even
invited to become part of it through
Reading and Imagination and
empathy on our own part
before launching into full-blown
discussion of the philosophical themes
and the cosmology and the development of
the human race and all this other stuff
we should pause for a moment to talk
about what happened with the characters
who were introduced in Hyperion and who
continued on through the fall of
Hyperion some of them are indeed dead
and remain dead you know Bron lamia the
council although the council Ship plays
a significant role in this and you know
there's Martin Salinas who's now at the
end of his life in these later two books
at almost three centuries uh in in the
future to that and uh you know there's a
few other characters so Saul Weintraub
is not himself going to come back but
his daughter Rachel who was aging
backwards and given to the shrike by
Saul uh in you know these two books
survives and turns out to be the monetta
who is the lover of Colonel casadas he
tells us in his story before he has his
epic battles with the shrike in fact a
whole bunch of strikes multiplied and
eventually dies and is you know entombed
in uh the time tombs
um so you know those are some important
characters we also have uh hetmanstein
who you know the true voice of the tree
the Templar who we think is dead but
he's not either and he is going to show
up in these books as well as we find
that the Templars and the ousters are in
this incredibly Rich fertile alliance
with each other that we'll talk about a
little bit later
uh the other two of course are the
priests and you know we get introduced
to Leonard Hoyt who is going to become
the pope who is born again over and over
and over again and it is kind of a
wicked character is he not but we also
have father duray the Jesuit follower of
tayar De Chardon who is you know
connected with him through the cruciform
parasite as we'll talk about in a bit
but we want to think about one person in
particular
and the reason we do is he's you know
he's here
on every single book
you see it in this you see it in this
you see it in this but now
interesting he's riding a raft and here
he's uh you know in a sort of protective
stance and that's the shrike in these
first two books the shrike is at best
something like a demon sent backwards in
time nobody's quite sure exactly by whom
maybe it's the AIS and the distant
future when they've developed the
ultimate intelligence sending it back as
a plague on humankind and in these two
books the shrike is confined to the
world of Hyperion
that changes in these two books where
the shrike
helps out uh Raul and Demian who's on
this mission to save the young girl the
12 year old Aina coming out of the time
tombs and then you know at other points
in time as well and the shrike now acts
as a helper a helper who kills people of
course and who destroys the Pax forces
going from person to person charring
them eating them up you know impaling
them all the things that the shrike
tends to do
the shrike also will jump from ship to
ship to ship and kill people on those
and then the shrike interestingly enough
is going to be resisting fighting trying
to destroy these particular AIS who've
been sent by the technocore
Nemesis is a you know prime example of
this she's the first one introduced then
she's got her siblings and they're
essentially like Terminator robots
except imagine the Terminator if it was
truly almost invulnerable and had all of
these tools at its disposal and could
move faster than any human being the
shrike is the creature that can actually
resist them
and what do we find out about the shrike
trike
in a certain way did Kill Colonel cassad
because Colonel cassad became the shrike
Colonel cassad is the you might say
ultimate human Warrior
and he is turned into this
whatever you want to call it demon
Avatar of War helper not quite robot
cyborg perhaps sent back to Aid and to
do all of these things so I ironically
the guy who saw the shrike is like this
I fought in all these wars and monetta
has been with me you know fighting
copulating with me uh where this this
great you know Warrior pair
um
the shrike is the Ultimate Enemy but the
shrike is himself so that's a very
interesting
sideline
for philosophical themes that I just
didn't want to leave out for anybody who
perhaps has read these two but hasn't
gotten into these and for anybody who's
gotten into these last two books of the
series you know that this is quite an
important plot point we might say
the fate of humanity where humanity is
going is an incredibly important theme
in these works in the entire Hyperion
cantos and we could say that there are a
number of important factions trying to
determine things and we also have you
know many many vignettes of people who
just want to live their lives who have
their own projects that they're engaged
in sometimes just attempting to survive
and live their way of life together but
we also have the church the Catholic
church in a very corrupt form and the
Pax mercantilius which work essentially
hand in hand with each other with the
church ruling over the packs and so that
is the you could say the inheritor of
one mode of humanity that was around
with the hegemony before the fall the
fall of the far Caster Network and the
breakdown of humans you know into each
of their own little private worlds there
are other religions out there there's
you know the Church of the final
atonement that has to do with the shrike
there are the Templars who have now left
and gone to join the ousters with whom
they were in League the entire time
there are practicing Jews there are
Muslims there are Hindus there are
Buddhists there are all sorts of other
people as well but the church is the one
that has become dominant throughout the
system and we we get to see them through
a lot of different vignettes we're
introduced to a new character
very early on the second main character
you could say not Raul and Demian but
the guy who is a you could call them a
third person Centric character we learn
about father Captain de soya right and
he is being tasked with a job that is
really quite bizarre and given this
index of papal Authority that allows him
to counterman just about anybody's
orders he's also going to be given a
ship which causes him every time that he
uses it to go from system to system to
die and then he has to be resurrected
right so
um you know there's some interesting
discussions of that we've already
brought up this you know earlier passage
about Hoyt and duray and all that uh you
know father Captain Federico De soya is
actually watching the pope and then
father Baguio had explained the
overwhelming sense of newness and wonder
that was the after effect of holy
Resurrection the church has turned
Resurrection into another Sacrament by
use of this cruciform parasite that has
been discovered all over the place and
which is sort of like a blessing right
anybody who is in good graces with the
church can accept the cruciform and when
they die they can be resurrected so
father Baguio says
the essential feeling of well-being
would always linger growing stronger
with each rebirth in Christ
Oya could see why the church held
suicide as one of its most mortal sins
punishable by immediate excommunication
since the glow to nearness to God was so
much stronger after tasting the ashes of
death Resurrection could easily become
addictive if the punishment for suicide
were not so terrible still aching from
the pain of death and rebirth his mind
and senses literally lurching from
vertigo father captained soil watches
the papal Mass approach the climax of
communion and it goes on and on all
right and they they assign him this this
job essentially to track down and bring
back to the Vatican this girl Aina who
is explained as being something kind of
like a a demon in some respects right
so um they tell them about this uh the
child is the daughter of a woman named
Braun lamia says Admiral Morrison does
the name mean anything to you father it
does but for a moment the soya cannot
think why then the verses of the cantos
come to mind and he remembers the female
Pilgrim in the story and Cardinal Lord
Asami says Braun lamia had sexual
intercourse with an Abomination a
cyberate a cloned human construct whose
mind was an artificial intelligence
residing in the Techno core do you
remember the history in the band poem
and uh he you know he tells them you
know that uh the woman in the
Blasphemous poem Braun lamia not only
had intercourse with the cyberate
Abomination but she bore the creature's
child
and this is the result Aina right she
was not fully human Whispers Cardinal
larsoni although the body of her father
the Keats hybrid was destroyed his AI
Persona was stored in a shrew and loop
shunt right we're almost certain that
this fetus was in touch with the
technocore Via that sybrid Persona so
the technocore is evil right and you
know the church is protecting Humanity
against it after the the great debacle
of the Fall that's what the soya thinks
so far
and he gets his uh crew
um Corporal Basin key Lancer uh uh red
egg and Sergeant Gregorius and all four
of them uh have to travel on this ship
all four of the men are shaken by the
experience of death the soya tries to
convince them it gets easier with
experience but his own shaken body and
which put the lie to these reassurances
here without counseling and therapy and
the welcoming Resurrection chaplains
each of the pack soldiers is dealing
with the trauma as best he can the
trauma of Resurrection the trauma of
dying and being brought back to life
right and so they go on their their
mission
um there we jump forward quite a bit and
there is an interesting discussion
that's happening about the uh
again father to soya and Cardinal
lurasami right
so lourdesami tells uh the soya that
this Abomination will destroy all that
as I said to you one year ago this is
not a child we seek it is a virus and we
know now once that virus comes the soil
listens his Holiness had one of his
visions
you are aware Frederico the Holy Father
is often visited by dreams granted by
God
and he goes on and he says it was one of
those sacred Revelations which prompted
the Holy Father to ask for you in this
service Federico he saw that your fate
and the salvation of our church and
Society were inextricably intertwined
and now the threat to the future of
humankind has been revealed in much
greater detail what is it this is indeed
the AI technocore's great attempt at our
destruction Federico the same mechanical
evil which destroyed old Earth which
preyed on Humanity's minds and souls
through their parasitic forecasters
which prompted the ouster attack that
presaged the fall the same evil is at
work here The sybrid Offspring this Aina
is their instrument this is why the
forecasters have worked for her when
they admit no one else this is why the
shrike demons laid thousands of our
people and soon May slay Millions
perhaps billions unless stop this
succubus will succeed in returning us to
the rule of the machine
Lord Asami stops his pacing but his
Holiness now knows that this hybrid
spawn is not only the agent of the core
she is the instrument of the machine God
soy understands when the Inquisition had
queried him about the cantos his insides
had turned to jelly at the thought of
punishment for having read the band poem
but this work on the index admitted that
the elements of the AI Core had been
working for centuries to produce an
ultimate intelligence a cybernetic deity
that would spread its power back through
time to dominate the universe indeed
both the cantos and official church
history acknowledge the battle across
time between this false god and our Lord
the Heats the Keats cyberid cybrids
actually since there had been a
replacement had falsely represented as a
candidate for the Messiah of the human
UI that's blasphemous tyardian concept
of an evolved human God in the in the
prohibited cantos the poem had talked
about empathy as being the key to human
spiritual Evolution the church had
corrected that pointing out that obeying
God's will was the source of Revelation
and salvation
now what do we actually discover
um
all of this is a lie
the church has been
In Cahoots with the technocore all this
time
and interestingly the ousters had never
engaged in any attack on the uh the
packs or originally the churches it was
arising or the hegemony now
um
Lord Asami also tells him as well
I must reveal something to you at this
moment Federico which billions of the
faithful will not learn for months
today this hour at the interstellar
Senate of Bishops
his Holiness is announcing a crusade a
crusade against the ouster Menace for
centuries we have defended ourselves the
Great Wall is a defense of stratagem
putting Christian bodies and ships in
lives in the way of the ouster
aggression but as of this day by the
grace of God the church and Pax will go
on the offensive
uh each world is being asked commanded
to devote planetary resources to build
one great ship one for each world and
they are using this Archangel technology
which translates them almost immediately
to where they're going killing the human
beings in the process and then they are
resurrected and then they begin to fight
now
we learn more as this book proceeds if
we move away from you know father to
soya who by the way is going to have a
very important crisis of conscience and
at the end of this book and uh try to
destroy the nemis our AI construct and
then he's going to actually uh switch
sides and use his Archangel ship in this
to try to
change the course of the battle as all
the pack ships are going after Aina
let's put that aside for a moment
so Aina and bettick and
Raul and Damian are talking with each
other and with Father Glaucus on this
ice world
and uh
Raul says um uh actually here we go Anna
says it's not the shrike chasing us you
know nor the Pax of course it's the
packs I said trying to get her to make
contact with reality they've been after
us since and it was shaking her head
adamantly no the Pax is after us because
the core tells it we're very dangerous
to them the core I said but it's ever
since the fall it's been Aina says alive
and dangerous after Gladstone and the
others destroyed the far Caster system
that provided the core with its neural
net it retreated but it never went far
Raul can't you see that the packs uh the
girl said simply my father his Persona
and mother shrone Loop explained it to
me before I was born the corps waited
until the church began being revitalized
under Paul DeRay Pope tayard the first
DeRay was a good man Raul my mother and
Uncle Martin knew him he carried two
cruciforms his own and father Leonard
Hoyts but Hoyt was weak
listen anything can happen tomorrow in
God's Grove she says I can die we can
all die and then she says just listen
tayard was murdered in his ninth Year my
father predicted it I don't know if it
was by technocore agents they used
cybrids or just Vatican politics but
when Lennar Hoyt was resurrected from
their shared cruciforms the core acted
it was the core that provided the
technology of allowing the cruciform to
revive humans without the sexlessness or
idiocy visited upon the bakura tribe on
Hyperion
but how I said how could the technical
AIS know how to tame the cruciform
Symbiote I saw the answer even before
she spoke
they created the cruciforms not the
current core but the UI they create in
the future it sent the things back in
time on Hyperion just as it did in the
time tombs tested the parasites on the
Lost tribe saw the problems little
problems like Resurrection destroying
reproductive organs and intelligence
yesterday and as she took my hand again
the corps was able to correct their
problems with their technology
technology they gave to the church under
its new pope Leonard Hoyt Julius VI I
began to understand a Faustian bargain I
said the Faustian bargain
the girl said all the church had to do
to gain the universe was sell its soul
and thus the Pax protector was born a
betic said softly political power coming
through the barrel of a parasite it's
the core that's after me after us
continue the child I'm a threat to them
not just to the church
I shook my head slowly how are you a
threat to the Courier one child
one child who was in touch with a
renegade Renegade cyber at Persona
before I was born she whispered my
father was loose Raul not just in the
data sphere of the megasphere but in the
meta sphere loose in The Wider
psycho carabinet that even the core was
terrified of medic mumbles lions and
tigers and bears and we're going to come
back to that in just a bit so I'm going
to leave off there we do need to say a
few more things about what what is
revealed to us about the AIS the
technocore and the church in the next
book so
what we find is
um
that umon this is uh Ayana telling Raul
about this did you know about the major
error in Uncle Martin's cantos Raul no I
said
um it was twofold somewhere in the
desert in Idaho called first he believed
with the technocore told my father
meaning the Keats sybrid about the one
about how they were the ones who had
hijacked Earth about everything umon was
lying to the John Keats hybrid why they
were just planning to destroy it the
girl looked at me but my mother was
there to record the conversation and the
core knew she would tell the old poet I
nodded slowly and that he would put it
as a fact and the poem he was writing
but why would they want to lie about
his second mistake was more subtle and
serious
Uncle Martin believed that the
technocore was Humanity's enemy she
continued why is that a mistake aren't
they our enemy
when the girl did not answer I held up
my hand five figures splayed one
according to the cantos the corps was
the real force behind the attack on the
hegemony that led to the fall of the
forecasters not the ousters the core the
church has denied that made the ousters
responsible are you saying that the
church is right and the old poet was
wrong no said it was the corps that
orchestrated the attack billions dead
the hegemony toppled the web destroyed
the fat line cut
the Techno core did not cut the fat line
she said softly all right taking a
breath that was some mysterious entity
your lions and tigers and bears but it
was still the core behind the attack
second dinner did not the technical use
the far casters as some sort of cosmic
leech to suck up human neural networks
for their damned ultimate intelligence
project every time someone far casts
they were being used by those autonomous
intelligences correct sadena three the
poem has Rachel the pilgrim saw
weintraub's child who comes backward in
the time tombs tell about a time to come
when the final war raged between the
correspond UI and the human Spirit was
this a mistake no Serena
four I'm beginning to feel a little bit
foolish didn't the core admit to your
father it created him created the John
Keats cyber just as a trap for what did
they call it the empathy component of
the human ultimate intelligence that's
supposed to come into existence sometime
in the future that's what they said
Serena
five
wasn't at the core as well as the Pax
hell the core ordering the packs that
tried to have you caught uh and uh
killed on Hyperion on Renaissance Vector
on God's Grove halfway across the spiral
arm yes she said softly and wasn't at
the core that created that female thing
that arranged to have poor abedics arm
sliced off on God's Grove and would have
had your head in a bag if it hadn't been
for the strikes intervention wasn't it
the core that's been trying to
kill me as well as you and will probably
kill us if we're ever stupid enough to
go into pack space and a nodded
but if all these facts are true I shook
my head and here we got the big
important shift
elements of the core attack the web
before the fall we know from my father's
visit with uman that the core was not in
agreement about many of its decisions
they used our neural networks for their
UI project but there's no evidence that
did humans any harm
right and she says
um the group of AIS called the ultimates
have created problems for Humanity in
the past and will in the future
including trying to kill you and me but
they're only part of the core
I shook my head I don't understand are
you really saying there are good AIS and
bad ai's don't you remember they
actually consider destroying the human
race and they may still do it
Ana said uh touch my knee again don't
forget Raul that Humanity has also come
close to destroying the human race
capitalists and Communists were ready to
blow up earth when that was the only
planet we lived on and the church is
ready to destroy the ousters even as we
speak genocide on a scale our race has
never seen before
the church and a lot of others don't
consider the ousters human beings I said
nonsense snap to Aina of course they are
they evolve from common human or Earth
human Origins just as the AI technocore
did all three races are orphans in the
storm all three races I repeated Christ
are you including the core in your
definition of humanity we created them
she said softly early on we used human
DNA to increase their computing power
and she goes on and says
um that here we go do you remember what
the AI uman said to the second seats Kai
Keith cybrid
um and there there's a repetition of
this empathy was supposedly the fleeing
component of the human AI UI part of our
evolved human consciousness in the
future come back in time
the hybrid was the John Keith cybert I
continued son of man and machine
that was Uncle Martin's second
misunderstanding the Keith sybirds were
not created to be the Refuge for empathy
in this age they were created to be the
instrument of that Fusion between core
and humankind to have a child in other
words
she is that child right and that is why
those elements of the core working
through the church are trying to kill
her right and the the you know there's a
lot in here that I'm going to kind of
skip over that shows the dependency of
the both the Pacs and the church on the
technocore
there's another discussion a little bit
later on which is very interesting
actually I'm not going to try to read
this because I want to save a little bit
of time
lifeless human bodies are taken from all
these worlds where the church is not the
dominant religion but other people seven
billion bodies transported by these two
religious orders Opus Dei which exists
in our time and core Unum right and
these are all
um
being put into this kind of spell by the
technocore which is going to be using
them later on
um and then you know the very
interesting discussion shortly after
this with the counselor Albedo the of
the technocore who came into you know
our purview in these two books engaging
with
um this uh uh Pax uh person and he tells
uh izozaki that the technocore was never
grouped into three warring elements the
core from its Evolution into
Consciousness a thousand years ago was
made up of thousands of distinct
elements and factions often warring
moreover more often cooperating but
always struggling to achieve a synthesis
of agreement towards the direction
autonomous intelligence and artificial
life should evolve that agreement has
never crystallized about the same time
that the technocore was evolving into
true autonomy well most humankind lived
on the surface of a near orbit around
one world Humanity had developed the
capacity to change its own genetic
programming they do this through through
not just genetic manipulation but
nanotechnology right and what we find is
this is where the ousters come from
elements of the emergent core which
favored alliance with the nanotech
universes discovered something that
terrified all elements of the core
what would that be
as you know our early Research into
Hawking Drive physics and faster than
light communication led to the plank
space medium what some have called the
void which binds evolving knowledge
about this underlying and unifying
structure to the universe led to our
creation the faster than light
communication the so-called fat line as
well as to the refined Hawking Drive the
forecasters that United the hegemonic
world web the planetary data spheres
evolving into megaspheres of core
directed data today's instantaneous
Gideon drive and even experiments into
anti-entropic bubbles within the
universe what we believe the time tubes
will become on Hyperion
but these gifts to humanity were not
without a price he goes on talking about
the neural Nets and the exploitation of
human beings and you know he goes on as
well giving more and more background and
then finally reveals to him
that the elements of the core under a
guise of an ouster attack launched a
final physical assault assault on the
world web despairing of destroying the
scattered human race in one stroke they
hope to destroy the advanced World web
Society
um and this led to you know the
breakdown of that other elements of the
core elements to devoted to not only
preserving the human race but some sort
of Alliance destroyed one iteration of
the John Kate cybrid but a second was
created and succeeded in his primary
Mission and so here's a revelation of
what was going on with uh Aina
he also tells him
about the crucifix
the origins of the cruciform LIE
shrouded in mystery but we humanist
elements of the core believe it was
developed in our future and brought back
it through time via the Hyperion time
tombs the failure of the Symbiote was
due to the simple demands of information
storage and retrieval in a human mind
there are neurons in a human body there
are approximately 10 to the 28th power
atoms the cruciform in order to restore
the mind and body of a human being must
not only keep track of these atoms and
neurons but remember the precise
configuration of the standing holistic
wave front which comprises the human
memory and personality it must provide
the energy to restructure these atoms
molecules bones muscles and memories so
the organism is reborn right the
cruciform alone cannot do that
successfully at best the bio machine can
reproduce a crude copy of the original
but the core
have the computing power to store
retrieve reshape and reform this
information into a human being and we
have done so for three centuries
so the core has been behind this
cruciform that offers Resurrection to
human beings all of the time
now
towards the very end of the book when
aena is being tortured to death in front
of Raul
by councilor Albedo and the various
Cardinals and things like that we get
one more interesting uh Revelation they
want her to forecast to free cast out of
there so that they can essentially
reverse engineer it and get even more
power right they would hurt her as he
says until she cannot stand it any
longer and when she Cast Away the core
instruments would measure everything to
the billionth of a nanosecond analyze
her use of the void and come up with a
way to replicate it the core would
finally have their far casters back not
in their crude Wormhole or Gideon Drive
manner but an instant and elegant and
eternally there's now we get a final
interesting Revelation here Aina says to
counselor Albedo I know where you live
the handsome gray man's mouth twitched
what do you mean I know where the core
the physical elements of the core are
nonsense he said no human being has ever
known the location of the core in the
beginning the core was a transient
entity floating in the crude datosphere
on Old Earth known as the internet then
even before the hajira
you moved your bubble memories and
servers and core storage and access to a
cluster of asteroids in Long orbit
around the sun far from the old Earth
you plan to destroy
during the days of hegemony
continued Aina the corps decided it was
prudent to diversify the physical core
components the bubble mammary matrices
deep underground and the nine Labyrinth
and worlds Flatline servers and the
orbital industrial complexes around Tao
City Center core entity Persona
traveling along far Caster comb bands
and the megasphere connecting it all
laced through the far Caster Rifts in
the void which binds but after the fall
the core got worried man of Gladstone's
attack on the far Caster medium gave you
pause even if the damage to your
megasphere was repairable you decided to
diversify further multiply your personae
miniaturize essential core memories and
make your parasiticism on the human
neural networks more direct
what actually is going on here
you wanted your neural parasiticism to
be more direct so your billions of core
entities each formed its surrounding
Matrix in cruciform shape and attach
themselves directly to your human hosts
every one of your core individuals now
has a human host of its own to live in
and Destroy at will you remain connected
via the old data spheres and new Gideon
Drive megasphere nodes but you enjoy
dwelling so close to your food source
so the cruciforms are not just a gift
from the core to human beings not just a
way in which the core has been
infiltrating things through a church
it's a direct form of parasitism upon
the human race involved through
something that appears to be life-giving
so that's you know giving you some
background some interesting information
about what's happening with these key
things the artificial intelligences are
autonomous autonomous intelligence is
the the Techno core the church the Pacs
human beings we could talk about the
ousters we're probably not going to have
too much time to discuss them they are
adopting a different perspective on
humanity and the cosmos now it's time
though that we talk about the void that
binds and aina's role in revealing what
it truly is to us human beings
this video has already grown a little
bit over long but I crave your
Indulgence because we have to go into
the last great philosophical theme that
is running throughout the entire series
but really becoming massively important
in these last two books of the Hyperion
cantos and that is what is the void
which binds now that is centrally
important but we also can't talk about
that without talking about the lions and
tigers and bears the other entities
and the one who teaches Aina one of the
main characters of this entire
second two-part novel that brings
everything to a close the Messiah the
Savior the teacher the lover of Raul and
Damian the really you know most
important character in the entire thing
because all of these are connected
together so we get a few things coming
up in endemian
she is talking with uh Raul about the
far casters and the fall and all of that
and now this is some great foreshadowing
she tells us that the uh megasphere the
data spheres the forecaster medium uh
you know were important and then Raul
says the forecaster medium that void
thing linked data sphere is right the
force and the hegemony electronic
government the all thing they all use
the megasphere as well as the fat line
to stay connected and then Ana says yeah
the megasphere actually existed on a
subplane of the fat line I didn't know
that I said the FTL medium had not
existed in my lifetime and then she says
do you remember what the last message on
the fat Line This instantaneous
communication network was before it went
down during the fall
yes I said closing my eyes the lines of
the poem did not come to me this time
the ending of the cantos had always been
too vague to interest me enough to
memorize all these stanzas despite
random's drilling some cryptic message
from the core I said something about get
off the line and quit tying it up
so Aina says the message was this
there will be no further misuse of this
channel you are disturbing others who
are using it to Serious purpose access
will be restored when you understand
what it is for right I said that's in
the cantos I think and then the hyper
string medium just quit working the core
sent that message and shut down the fat
line
then Ayanna has a revelation
the core did not send that message
it didn't I said stupidly who did good
question said the child when my father
talked about the metasphere The Wider
datum plan that was somehow connected to
or by the void which binds he always
used to say it was filled with lions and
tigers and bears
lions and tigers and bears I repeated
these were old Earth animals I didn't
think any of them made the hajira I
didn't think any of them were around to
make the trip not even their stored DNA
hmm I said Aina I'd like to meet them
someday here we are and they will in
fact by the end meet the lions and
tigers and bears the others who use the
void which binds
a little bit later in this work uh she
brings that up again and
um
she talks about well Raul asks how are
you a threat to the core your one child
and she says one child who is in touch
with a renegade sybrid Persona before I
was born my father was loose Raul not
just in the datosphere or the megasphere
but in the meta sphere loose in The
Wider
psychosarabinet that even the core was
terrified of lions and tigers and bears
muttered a betic exactly today you know
when my father's Persona penetrated the
core megasphere he asked the AI woman
what the corps was afraid of they said
they didn't range further in the
medisphere because it was full of lions
and tigers and bears I don't get it
kiddo I said I'm lost
so they they go out and start talking
about old Earth and all of that
interestingly I'm gonna reveal a little
bit abetic is one of those lions and
tigers and bears he has been there to
observe what Humanity in the technocore
are doing
um now Aina is massively important she's
not just this juncture point between the
technocore and Humanity she is also
somebody who is in a certain way in
touch with the void which binds in a way
that is at that point unique to her
although we find out in the story that
she's already given communion in this to
one other person
Uncle Salinas years and years before and
he is ready to do it now what what is
this communion it's actually a you know
a genetic component in her
body which can be transferred by
partaking in her blood and it changes
human beings fundamentally how so well
she tells us about this virus right and
it's connected to you know love being a
basic force of the universe and and Raul
says you talked about teaching the
physics of lava understanding love is a
basic force of the universe is that the
virus and she says that's the source of
the virus what I teach is how to use
that energy
how I whispered
Ayanna says let's say there's four steps
four stages four levels this is
absolutely centrally important
the first
is learning the language of the Dead she
said
and then Raul tries to interrupt her and
she's the second is learning the
language of the living I nodded not
understanding either phrase the third is
under is hearing the Music of the
Spheres she whispered in my reading at
telusian West I'd run across this
ancient phrase it was all mixed up with
astrology the pre-scientific age on Old
Earth Kepler's little wooden models of a
solar system on and on volumes of double
talk I had no idea what my friend was
talking about and how it could apply to
an age when Humanity moved faster than
light through the spiral arm of the
Galaxy the fourth step her gaze turned
inward again is learning to take the
first step now what is all this what's
going on with this so the language of
the dead the dead are not completely
gone they are there in the void which
binds the language of the living being
able to see things from the perspective
of those existing in the present time
The Music of the Spheres is literally
understanding the universe and not just
a cognitive understanding but a grasp
that is also affective the first step is
being able to free cast to move
instantaneously across vast distances
using the void which binds sort of like
the fire casters did but it's revealed
that the far casters are actually
free casting not the other way around
now a little bit later and we get these
great teaching sessions going on she is
going to talk about the um
void which binds again and she tells us
this
the void which binds is a
multi-dimensional medium with its own
reality and as the core was soon to
learn its own topography the Hawking
Drive was not and is not a drive at all
in the classic sense but an entry device
which touches on Planck's based
topography just long enough to change
coordinates in the four-dimensional
space-time Continuum far Caster portals
on the other hand allow actual entry to
the void which binds medium to humans
the reality was obvious step through a
hole in space-time here exit
instantaneously via another far Caster
hole there my uncle Martin had a
forecaster home with adjoining rooms on
dozens of Worlds far casters created the
hegemonys world web the precursor before
the fall all these worlds were
interconnected by the forecasters which
were given to them by the technocore
right
the core did not perfect the Hawking
Drive the forecaster and the fat line
for human convenience indeed the core
never perfected anything in their
dealings with the with the void which
binds the core knew from the beginning
the Hawking Drive was little more than a
failed attempt to enter Planck space
driving spacecraft via Hawken Drive was
comparable they knew to moving an
ocean-going vessel by setting off a
series of explosions at its Stern and
riding the waves crudely effective
wildly inefficient and she goes on she
says they knew despite all appearances
to the contrary there were not millions
of fire Caster portals only one all
forecaster portals were actually a
single entry door to Planck space
manipulated across space-time to provide
the functioning illusion of so many
doors if the court attempted to explain
the truth to humanity they might have
used the analogy of a flashlight being
being rapidly flashed around a closed
room there were not many sources of
light only one in Rapid transition but
they never bothered to explain this in
truth they've kept the secret to the day
she goes on and she says the what the
corps realized in their earliest
experiments was that the void which
binds was the perfect medium for their
own existence it would give them a
hiding place which was at once nowhere
and everywhere a hiding place from
Humanity who might want to turn them off
but then they discovered it's not empty
right behind its meta-dimensional Hills
and deep in its fuldum Quantum space
Arroyos lurked something different
someone different there were
intelligences there the core probed then
recoiled in awe and Terror of the
potential power of these others these
were the lions and tigers and bears
spoken of by uman the Coors Retreat had
been so Hasty its reconnaissance so
incomplete it had no idea where in real
time in space these lions and tigers and
bears dwelt or if they existed in real
time at all nor could the core AIS
identify the others as having evolved
from organic life as Humanity had done
or from artificial life as they had so
the core
and with as many many factions is
terrified of what it discovers and it
keeps this from humanity and it argues
about it with themselves
such power was beyond comprehension the
core's reaction was pure panic and
immediate Retreat this discovery and
panic happened just as the corps had in
initiated the actions of destroying old
Earth
and the home planet then disappeared not
destroyed as it seemed to the humans not
saved as the court hoped just gone the
core knew that the lions and tigers and
bears had to be the ones who took the
Earth but as to how and to wear for what
reason they had no clue they computed
the amount of energy necessary to far
cast an entire planet away and again
began quaking in their hyper life boots
such intelligences could explode the
core of an entire galaxy to use as an
energy source as easily as humans could
light a campfire on a cold knife Knight
The Core entities hyperlife bricks
in their fear and so the core you know
creates side braids to try to understand
things she also explains that there are
not three camps in the technocore there
are billions the core is the ultimate
exercise in Anarchy hyper parasitism
carried to its highest power core
elements Vie for power in alliances
which might last centuries or micro
seconds billions of the parasitic
personae ebb and flow and Unholy
Alliance is built to control or to
predict events and she tells us that a
faction called the reapers are actually
the largest block greater block than the
ultimates and it was that the Reapers
who created and first controlled the
physical construct known as the shrike
now going on a little bit further that's
probably enough about the core at this
point what about the void which binds so
she's asked
about this when she's teaching on the
the you know essentially Buddhist Planet
someone says tell us about the void
which binds and here we get sort of a
great revelation
once upon a time there was the void and
the void was beyond time in a real sense
the void was an orphan of time and a
orphan of space
but the void was not of time not of
space and certainly was not of God nor
is the void which binds God in truth the
void evolved long after space and time
it staked out the limits to the universe
but Unbound by time untethered in Space
the void which binds has leaked backward
and forward across the Continuum to the
Big Bang being beginning and the little
whimper end of things
then she goes on and she says the void
which binds is a minded thing
it comes from minded things many of whom
were in turn created by minded things
the void which binds a stitch of quantum
stuff woven with plank space plank time
lying under and around space-time like a
quilt cover around and under cotton
batting the void which binds is very
very important is neither mystical nor
metaphysical it flows from and responds
to the physical laws of the universe but
it is a product of that evolving
universe I'm going to pause here for a
second because at another point in this
book Ana says Evolution itself evolves
right so it's not a fixed set of laws
there's actually a complicated
growing more to Evolution itself on the
void which binds is uh clearly connected
with that so she says that the void is
structured from thought and feeling it
is an artifact of the universe's
consciousness of itself and not merely
of human thought and feeling the void
which binds is a composite of a hundred
thousand sentient races across billions
of years of time it is the only constant
in the evolution of the universe the
only common ground for races that will
evolve grow flower fade and die millions
of years and hundreds of millions of
light years apart from each other and
there is only one entrance key to the
void which binds so what we have here is
a incredible Revelation about this right
it is something that pervades everything
and it is itself
sentient and the locus of sentience and
this is where we can do the things that
Aina was talking about learn the
language of the Dead learn the language
of the living you know uh hear the
language of the Spheres and step make
that first step into the void which
binds now she shares how this becomes
possible for human beings in this
communion with the void which binds
and she tells the ones who are going to
partake of it before you partake of this
I must remind you this is a physical
change not a spiritual one your
individual quest for God or
Enlightenment must remain just that your
individual Quest this moment of change
will not bring Satori or salvation it
will bring only change and she tells how
this works in the cells of my blood our
unique DNA and RNA Arrangements along
with certain viral agents which will
invade your body starting through the
digestive Linings of your stomachs and
ending in every cell of your body these
invasive viruses are somatic that is
they will be passed along to your
children
these physical changes will allow you
after some training to touch the void
which binds more directly thus learning
the language of the dead and of the
living eventually with much more
experience and training it may be
possible for you to hear The Music of
the Spheres and take a true step
elsewhere and she says this is not
metaphysics
this is a mutant viral agent
and so this communion will not offer you
immortality it ensures that death will
be our common end right I do not offer
you eternal life for instance Satori if
these are the things you seek most
dearly you must find them in your own
religious searchings I offer you only a
deepening of The Human Experience of
life and connection to others
human or not who have shared that
commitment to living
so she says as well that there is Duty
discomfort and great danger who partake
of this and in doing so become teachers
of the themselves of the Void which
binds as well as fellow carriers of this
new virus of human choice so what she's
offering is a physical change that will
open up new possibilities for those
human beings to partake in a universe
that is much richer than we had
suspected
um I'm going to skip over this this
passage here it's enough to say that the
core had been rendering the void which
binds and also destroying some of the
personalities that were stored there the
voices of the dead and doing great
damage to them uh not understanding what
it was it was engaged in
a little bit later uh towards the end
she talks about love and she says
remember our discussion long ago about
the physics of love and Raul says love
is an emotion kiddo not a form of energy
and she says it's both Raul it truly is
and it's the only key to unlocking the
universe's greatest supply of energy and
he says are you talking about religion
and she says no no I'm not talking about
religion
and I'm talking about physics an
engineering project two and a half
billion years old and barely begun and
then the last passage that I'll bring up
is when
he's about ready to free cast himself
and he's he's in the
um
Schrodinger cage
and he says Aina heard the Music of the
Spheres she resonated with the void
which binds which resonates in turn to
sentient life and thought and she used
the almost illimitable energy of the
Void to take the first step to travel
the void to where those voices
waited she'd once said the void tapped
into the energy of quasars the exploding
centers of galaxies black holes and
black matter
love was the prime mover in the universe
Anna had once said to me
I saw now what she had meant and how it
worked much of the Music of the Spheres
was created by the elegant harmonies and
the chord changes of love
free casting to where one's loved one
Waits learning a place after having
traveled there with the one or ones you
love loving to see new places
and he says suddenly I understood why
our first months together had been what
it seemed at the time like useless
wanderings from world to world
we had been learning how to love them
Anna had swept abedic and me with to
these places touching them sniffing
their air feeling their sunlight on her
skin seeing them all with friends with
someone she loved learning The Music of
the Spheres so that it could be played
later so this is the vision that Simmons
is offering us as the culmination
of this massive Hyperion cantus
adventure story Space Opera
metaphysical meditations it all comes
down to love and not in a reductive way
but as the key that opens up the
entirety of the universe beyond what we
see here feel sense to a greater
possible communion with the totality of
intelligent beings what a vision to end
on and that is where we will end this
long discussion of this second half of
Dan Simmons Hyperion campus